all of us have way too much complexity
in our lives too many devices our kids
going on building different places at
work we have all kinds of things were
supposed to be doing and and realizing
is there a way to be simple and then
noticing that some of I think the most
effective people actually are simple and
so that kind of led us to just start
exploring what what's what's the value
of simple rules and simplicity we
started studying companies and their
product development processes and we
realized that that there were companies
that had these very complicated product
development processes and what would
happen was they would do the wrong
product really efficiently and
conversely we would see these other
companies where there were no rules at
all and they were having a great time
getting nothing done and we saw that
then again this there was this sort of
intermediate a few simple rules who
who's in charge of what what kind of a
product do we do but just maybe four or
five rules that the sort of constrain
what people did but yet gave them some
flexibility to to innovate there's
really three steps of coming up with
simple rules one of them is what's the
objective what are we really trying to
achieve here is it is it revenue is it
growth is it is it notoriety so what's
what's the underlying objective that
business objective we're trying to
achieve and so profitability and growth
for example would be two different
things so what are we trying to achieve
and that's usually fairly
straightforward for business people to
come up with what's harder to figure out
is what's the bottleneck process what's
the repeat thing that we do often that
really keeps us from achieving that
objective so an interesting example is
actually Google back in the day there
were some problems at Google early on
where they weren't getting enough
product improvement in their in their
search engine and some of their other
products so the product development
wasn't as good as they wanted it to be
thought a bit about you know to
reorganize product development you know
what do we do well then as I thought
about more the real bottleneck was
keeping them from from being successful
was the quality computer scientists and
so they realize the real bottleneck was
the hiring process and what we need to
do is get top-flight computer scientist
because top-flight computer scientists
are substantially better than the
average computer scientist and then they
develop some simple rules that were
things you might not expect us things
like look for people who are eccentric
because they're more creative so people
who ride a unicycle climb the Himalayas
do something strange and look for people
always always prefer referrals from
other Googlers because the idea there
was Googlers know what good Googlers
look like and they want to work with
them and then the third one was stop the
stop the hiring process if you see
anything phony or fake on the resume
because we want high integrity people so
the the point here is that the objective
was not what they first thought it was
good it looks to me the bottom like was
not what they first thought it was been
going to be it ultimately became
something around computer science hire
hires and then finally developing the
rules that's the third step is what are
the rules and that's usually a
combination of looking back at your own
data so for example I worked with a
company in biotech where partnerships
were very important and they looked back
at their data trying to figure out when
were we successful what more we so try
to understand from your own data another
strategy is to bring outside experts you
come up with rules by thinking about
what your objective is trying to figure
out what that bottleneck is which is
probably the hardest thing to do and
then developing rules partly from your
own experience partly working with
outsiders to come up with them
you can make faster decisions when your
simple because you only have to think of
a few factors the second reason is that
there are certain situations that some
simplicity actually is not only faster
but it's actually better than using
complicated formulas and lots of data
because if you use too much if you use a
lot of data on the formulas what you
tend to do is over fit the past which is
a poor predictor future so so it's
actually because what you're trying to
do is predict the future and and and and
given let's say given you have a set of
data and there are multiple ways you
could fit that data
the simplest fitting of that data is the
most likely to be predictive of the
future and then it's better because
people actually do it so for example if
I give you you know three rules to
remember for partnerships or three rules
remember for investing or or dieting you
know you are more likely to remember and
do it even if you're stressed out you're
busy you're got a zillion things to do
you can say oh wait a minute I'm
supposed to think about hiring people
and I remember these three rules and
that's all I have to remember so it's
particularly effective when you're just
stressed out with too much to do
it works best when you involve the
people in your in your organization so
not just you at the top deciding what
the rules are but but getting getting
the talent below you thinking about it
and participating in the process of
coming up with the rules looking at the
data testing them out the stopping rules
are the hardest to learn when do I when
do i back off we're doing is we're
trying to sell to a client and when is
it's time to say no we're developing a
product when is the time to stop we have
an investment when do we sell it
those those the stopping rules are the
hardest for people to learn and and and
I think maybe ironically they're also
related to higher performance so getting
probably one of the biggest mistake
businesspeople make as they stay in
something too long and a stopping rule
helps you get out of that people are
really good at starting and they're
really bad at stopping and so a rule
that says I'm done with this partner I'm
done with the sales call I'm done with
this product I'm done this person I'm
not hiring them whatever the process is
that you have a rule that says I stopped
when it's time to change is when they
don't seem to be working anymore or the
situation to somehow changed one of the
examples I think that's pretty obviously
people would know well it's the
Moneyball the Oakland A's Moneyball
which was focused on among other things
getting players with high on-base
percentage
well once everybody else in the major
leagues figures that out they're doing
it too they're paying more than you are
and the Boston Red Sox are winning the
pennant and you're not and so when
you're when your rules are starting to
be copied by competitors when or when
the situation's change as it did for the
A's you have to change up the rules